i know this look is kind of crazy i like
it i would go to the bodega to get hot
cheetos in this look
hi everyone my name is mean i'm a video
director based in brooklyn new york and
i'm going to be doing a little look
today
for the one and only barrymore it's this
look
if you haven't already guessed already
sunny look kind of sunny cloudy vibes i
actually wore a version of this look on
her show
i'm so glad to introduce you to makeup
instagram god it's me and jan
that was a very very surreal experience
so i'm gonna walk you through this whole
thing it looks kind of scary but i'm
telling you
it's pretty easy so let's just get right
into it
starting off with getting that hair out
of the face
just makes it easier to do everything
and i am going to
just do a little bit of concealer so i
was mentioning on the
show to drew that when you're doing
crazy makeup looks first of all there's
no rules when it comes to makeup
but i find that if you're doing very
intense
colors a lot of makeup on the eyes
that it really helps to balance it out
by doing something
fresh on the skin i
very very rarely wear foundation i will
instead opt for
a concealer this is the elf concealer
and just apply that kind of all over my
face
in lieu of foundation so this is an
eyelid primer i
always prime my eyes before
i put on any eyeshadow or eyeliner
because i have very oily eyelids i'm
gonna actually go over that eyelid
primer with a little bit of
white this is a white one looks a little
not so white anymore but
white eyelid primer on top so i get that
longevity but i also get
a little nice white base and that's
going to help any
like pastel or light eye shadows that i
put over top
really pop so i'm going to go in with a
little bit of
this lavender purple it's from this hip
dot rio palette
apply that to the inner corner into the
crease
we're going to blend a lot here later
because sunsets are hazy
and that's the vibe using the same brush
because i'm lazy
and go into the center kind of blend
a little bit of pink into that
beautiful purple shade do a little bit
of yellow
up here i'm honestly just winging it at
this point
a little bit of that pink blend it into
the outer corner i like to use
darker colors toward the outer corner of
the eye i just think that it
helps kind of elongate the eye shape
gives you a good definition there
secret here for blending is you don't
want to get rid of the gradation of
colors if you just go in with windshield
wiper motions they're all going to blend
together and it's not going to look
great what you want to do
is go in with small circular
movements so you end up blending it out
on the edges you still get a soft and
diffused line
but you're not blending all the colors
together
so once that's all blended if you feel
like you've lost a little bit of
definition anywhere you can always go
back in
with your original colors and just tap
a little bit of extra color on top
i'm gonna put a little bit of the same
colors kind of mimicking those colors on
my lower lash line
going with the purple toward the inner
corner
going in with the pinks on the outer
corner
they might seem hard they're not hard
you take a little
honestly you can take a little a little
domed brush
kind of like this is very small you see
like my finger it's very small brush
this is usually used for like smudging
out the lash line these little domed
brushes are great for clouds or
you can honestly use a cotton swab a
q-tip dip it into
your pomade really saturate
the top of it get it get that product
really in there
then you're gonna go in and start
putting your clouds on
these can be anywhere you want really
you want to
create this like wabi-sabi imperfect
kind of cloud formation i usually do
three little dots
like that the first one and again like
clouds are like snowflakes they're not
all the same
there's something to be said about how
amazing it is the feeling of feeling
yourself and feeling good so i'm gonna
leave you with that
thank you so much to drew for having me
on your show thank you so much for
watching i hope you guys tried this look
if you do please tag me because i'd love
to see them
and i will see you guys next time bye
[Music]
you